[Music]
so you know we we love our American
neighbors to the north sometimes we
forget about them not of Canada mm-hmm
yeah I forget that they're a different
country it just feels like the Midwest
that's bigger like us that part of the
United States that's too cold I just
feel like they're like San Francisco but
all our nice neighbors to the north yeah
when we think of them we think of maple
syrup hi miss hey
hockey but we don't think of crime when
we think of Canadians none you cry cry
well they just uncovered a tow-truck
turf war mm-hmm
with over 200 charges linked to
organized crime it is some gangster [ __ ]
man you guys watch good girls no explain
to us what is what is going on don't
want NBC it's these three moms broke
okay they robbed they robbed a [ __ ]
supermarket grocery store and they
somehow end up in the Mafia because
basically they were on someone else's
turf oh I know that from then they have
to like do all these jobs and they like
it really gets them into this life of
crime but they can't get out of it
that's cute
one of the jobs is they have to go to
Japan at Canada to me it's a exchange
counterfeit money and like basically
washed it saw the preview it looks funny
it's it's not funny oh it's it's really
good and there's like funny moments I
guess because like the bean mom is like
pretty real she's just sick of being a
[ __ ] Pinterest mom and then she like
what she has to do cuz she's good at it
but then she's like but I [ __ ] hate
it she ends up really liking the crime
hmm so she the others who want to get
out and she's like yeah me too she gets
them back in all the time it's like a
reverse Bay yeah is Anna Faris andis no
has anybody we know in it um the the
girl from what you in Beth oh okay so
she's in Mad Men I think
and then no I don't know the other
people premise though it's really good I
watched it randomly because there was
nothing else on like I spent in between
series and I got hooked this is a Steve
approve of the show yeah yeah we're both
enjoy
yeah we need Steve to like it in order
like sexist because I could relate to
the whole like yeah my wife likes One
Show by hate - 40 - there's like in the
Mafia guy you guys were gonna watch it
so you have it's not a spoiler yeah do
they get naked or what I don't have to
what you have to watch yeah tits or gtfo
bro yeah so hi when I think of the tow
truck industry I do think of like kind
of gray area you might be linked to the
Armenian mafia or something like that
you just don't know right yeah the same
thing in Canada right lacks regulations
and they found a whole awesome way I
shouldn't say awesome interesting an
ingenious way of tying in truck
companies rental car companies drivers
that will commit insurance fraud where
the tow truck will come in like pick it
up and they have body shops it's like
the slow link they need to stop telling
us the details because now we can
improve it and do our own but I love the
details tell me - detail please right
but beyond that because the profits are
so [ __ ] good and now they have this
whole like link live like fraud and
getting money from insurance and all
this stuff they got greedy and then they
started burning each other's vehicles up
and fighting for territory and so like
they'll just have some cars like that
that's just burned down or you lose your
dream so your tow trucks sorry buddy
wait what part looks burned oh the front
it's like it's like completely idioms
like that look at my car what
now that one looks like it's really
burnt so don't just wake up one day and
the tow trucks just burnt you know that
happens a good girls too so they own she
wants also be good
they own a car lot yeah they teamed up
with auto repair shop really yeah it's
crazy dude and so the insurance
companies started to go hmm because you
know they use math and she'll be like
hmm there's a lot more accidents and
problems happening more than usual
trucks kitchen on fire I need to
investigate with these specific
companies to it's not like Glendale mmm
that's what I do they're like the I
don't want to say whoo but like
Armenians yeah they think because they
run the insurance things or whatever
they get into accidents because their
homies are gonna like cash them out and
stuff mmm I like insurance rates are
crazy high over there did they say what
part of Canada the GTA did you know that
land oh yeah no no Greater Toronto Area
I didn't know what's called the GTA
that's so sick cuz all this crime is
happening in also the sarong is a
different accent Toronto though then
it's like no no no I'm saying they have
a whole way of speaking out there like
Toronto Toronto slang like Toronto like
you know it's very like I were like um
like yo I had bare Tings fam Beartooth
what you sayin in Ireland talk yeah the
Caribbean Jamaican yeah there's a big
Jamaican Caribbean influence in Toronto
yeah so it's very like oh like what you
say in a knife am are you gonna reach
them oh I bare Tings last night famine
whatever is a drink talks like that yeah
yeah so is there a lot of Caribbean
people there is that why
yeah that would it's also the the big
influence from because that's how they
talk in the Caribbean in like Ibiza
yeah so like I don't know though I don't
know there was a black English accent
because my friends are the London rubber
the London rappers yeah so London slang
and Toronto slang are super similar
because it's all Jamaican influence do
they say in it in there they do say in
there
you got watch love island make your all
kinds of different things I don't know
man [ __ ] East la la things in it bro
like admit brother su admit a say bro
London talk as a way of making you agree
with what they're saying they got
something in it yeah yeah in it yeah
yeah yeah yeah if you've been watching
the top boy boy oh you don't want stop
boy I don't I watch the [ __ ] peaky
blinders and every time Tom Hardy's on
on screen he's like in it yeah yeah yeah
I thought those guys were Irish oh well
its UK UK you know how stupid I was I
didn't know that Ireland had their own
language alright
[ __ ] gay leg yeah cuz I stopped by
Dublin right and there's talking some
kind of language and I was like what if
this [ __ ] matters make English around
[Laughter]
people their accents cuz you know like
in London right you have the different
you have the Amy Winehouse English and
you have the [ __ ] Queen's English
right right I just thought you didn't
know the more dragger English was the
Leprechaun English army McGregor yeah
that was their English and in the
Scottish is the groundskeeper Willie
English right right right so like they
don't have their own language or they do
I don't know like do Welsh people's yeah
they do have a differently good Scottish
a Scottish Welsh it in Welsh
yes is well there's not a lot of people
that speak it though so everything you
know violin they talk about it and they
were surprised because they were both
from Welsh and they could speak some of
it or what could I do
one could just understand we don't they
don't get the smartest people when I
show either Christian Bale is Welsh
right does he speak Welsh dating show
the British dating show it's so [ __ ]
good I know it's what you're talking
about it the producers don't give a [ __ ]
like they don't
like it's not like bachelor where
there's like an organized thing where
you know like someone's gonna get
eliminated on this day and there's a
ceremony or whatever it's like they just
throw people out and they'll just kick
people out and then they'll break up
couples they'll have the public vote and
like it's all pretty much live too in a
sense yeah it's pretty real no it's like
the next day oh [ __ ] like that time yeah
that's fine oh this [ __ ] gets real
though beyond just like intimidation
burning cars and whatever they've been
charged with first one guys charged with
first-degree murder three charges of
attempted murder the suspects range
about like from 20 to 49
it's literally some mafia [ __ ] so they
confiscated these guns whoo this [ __ ]
looks crazy man that [ __ ] looks like a
homemade yeah what is what war - gun it
looks like someone [ __ ] welded then
yeah sparks Italian or the upper
receiver that's just like oh yeah like a
submachine yeah yeah they found 16
handguns 13 shotguns right if their ban
guns back people still get guns yeah
that's true
they found 1.5 kilos of cocaine meth
that's illegal it's illegal but they
didn't they have over half a million
dollars yeah so this is a legit like tow
truck game well there's lots of this
lots of like gang [ __ ] there's like a
hood [ __ ] in Canada cause like every
city kind of has its like it's bad areas
you know like its hood areas and whatnot
but it's so cute you mean no matter what
country you go through there's still
people that are bad and people that are
greedy and good things get corrupt is
there a country where we can go to that
doesn't have none of that
Sweden Somalia Jamar here College Weiss
house they could be the worst trees you
know why is because we are the gang god
damn it can you speak out on no you'll
die but you don't want to cuz it's so
good
yeah well language they speak over their
Jamali oh god like a little bit of
English what's the exit what kind of
accent is whatever I feel like for today
I say two days like today is like
ancient bay that's what that's how Spain
was why they have the list because of
the king back then had a list so
everyone cared to how he spoke I
seriously respect and then that just
carried on I could be wrong probably
wrong I like a grapevine and then retain
it in my memory and then say it later
and someone's like that's wrong why did
I believe it for so long I mean I like
these and I want everybody to talk like
these and they talk again you change it
up to like in it bro and their bravia
new bro that's what was it you know
what's crazy I saw this one video of why
is our English so different from the
British English and do we speak it
properly but you know what actually it's
not no we are we're actually closer to
the old English than they are
it is great a linguist guy was saying
how like um America kind of preserved
more of the og English and Britain kept
like evolving it or changing it because
the Royals never wanted to sound like
commoners so they kept changing the
Royals kept changing how they speak and
then the commoners would just keep
copying how the upper-class spoke and
and so that [ __ ] started to change
whereas the Americans in our English it
was almost like we kept the original way
of doing things is the whole like oh la
is like something they put on
additionally just the differentiate
differentiate and then it just became
something yeah I'm a real shin yeah it's
crazy
yeah bottle I forgot which one it was I
don't know if it was southern English or
northern English that was more if you
have a British accent I already think
you're smart oh yeah immediately and if
you've glasses and a British accent
monocle
you're even smarter than the monocle
with the half like ones like like for
reading yeah the smaller they get the
smaller get the smoke they could be
talking about some stupid [ __ ] but if a
flat earther with a monocle came and
says actually
the world is a flat place and I'll be
like oh [ __ ] for real the weirdest [ __ ]
is hearing like a British kid that's
barely learning how to talk like when
they're like when they're going and they
have that like more posh accent and like
I saw some video with this kid was
literally like mummy I think I think I'm
hungry right now could I have some
double glass like why do you sound so
smart you know like an you [ __ ]
barely even like you know charlie bit my
finger talks like that [ __ ] tighter
sometimes cause he's watching YouTube
videos so my mom it's a car no it's a
car not car calm you gotta teach them
all the way LA [ __ ] bro like mom got a
pork the core outside mom the core pork
it outside yeah you bring him back Boo
Boo's mom New Zealand the kids are have
an American accent cuz there's home all
day watching American TV like yeah they
started to pick up the accent it was on
the radio show Oz and your but New
Zealand accents are so cool I know but I
guess there's a whole thing where the
like a lot of kids are just picking up
American accents it's a culture that
they try to get into yeah well that's
that's on TV the whole times I've
debated like when I finally start having
babies talking to them in a British
accent like the first so they have
automatic okay
why is your natural voice a bad English
accent cool
[Music]
[Music]